hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and ah ha
ha ha I'm checking in on you sorry
how are you I'm in health Helsinki I'm
in Helsinki I got I just did Stockholm
the other night I did Copenhagen 2 shows
the night before and [ __ ] Iceland on
Monday been having a great time Joe
bartnick coming over here like he's
always been over here I actually asked
him on cuz he's been crushing so hard
and so not like in his head you know
about being over here thinking oh I'm
gonna do a joke about ducks do they have
ducks do I need to say canard
he hasn't been doing any of that [ __ ]
and he's been killing so I asked him
last night when we were in Stockholm I
was like how many times you've been over
here and he goes Europe that's like yeah
and he goes never that's why people love
Joe Bartnik because Joey B is Joey B no
matter where he is yeah he's been
killing and I've been I've been having
some good sets over here trying out the
new [ __ ] the race against time you know
I heard Joe Rogan say the other day that
he was put in six months of work and
he's got a new hour that he's happy with
you know because his special came out
and you know I was I don't know I just
get I get like amped up when I hear [ __ ]
like that but uh so I'm trying not to
jump the gun if you guys are you want to
hear my process my process about
building a new hour is I usually dump
this [ __ ] I'm most sick of first you
know what I mean and it's a weird time
it's a weird time for your act because
what happens is you get really excited
about the new stuff and then the old
stuff still works and nobody's really
seen it yet but you know you get rid of
it so you feel like you ever go on a
date with somebody you know and you
you're gonna break up with them and
you're out to dinner and and she's just
like you want dessert you're like now
now let's wrap this up that's how that's
that's what you have to fight with your
jokes like you start trying to wrap them
up and then jokes that were funny are
now not funny because you're trying to
rush through them so I kind of figured
that out the last couple of nights and
had some great shows and I don't know I
did Stockholm last night and some of the
stuff people said to me in the stage was
making me a little nervous where I was
like you know I said something I'm not
the big political guy but uh I've been
doing this joke over here was where I
just go you know and as you all know in
America right now we currently have our
greatest president of all time
you know people usually laugh because
generally speaking they don't like him
and it was sort of quiet instant there
was a couple people just went like yeah
whoo it's just like really and I hung
out with some people afterwards and they
were kind of saying that oh and I
mentioned how I mentioned during the
show I was saying this is nothing
against people from Stockholm they just
let me know where people are kind of at
and they was saying I go can I ask you a
question I go is this [ __ ] gonna
start up again over here and they kind
of got a little uncomfortable like and
kind of said yeah I don't know if they
were joking or what the [ __ ] meaning
another world war I don't know it's
weird then I kind of talked to some
people afterwards and granted I only
talked to two people and it was their
opinion but they were saying that it's
just kind of getting like racist or
whatever not like it ever went away I
don't know people are [ __ ] awful but
those two people I talked to and nice
and you know something 90% of the
[ __ ] people that I talked to a nice
and you know the rest are like racists
or like hardcore feminists you know just
people you can't even have a [ __ ]
conversation with astoundingly ignorant
to walk through the
[ __ ] world thinking that you have all
the answers and you're gonna be the one
that solves it how long have people been
on this planet I don't know when did
Jesus die [ __ ] 2020 years ago then he
had what a cup like five hundred years
before him is that what it was I you
know I have no idea how long people have
been on this planet hang on a second let
me look that up
how long have people this be funny just
to leave it there to see what they
suggest that I should searcher
how long have people no suggestion then
I can't say here right that's Eve that's
even too stupid for Google
how long do people been on on the earth
this will take me to Scientology well
before we were in a spaceship um how
long have people been on earth do you
imagine if Scientology is right there
was some spaceship right and then they
just [ __ ] dropped us down here with
absolutely no [ __ ] what I mean how
[ __ ] advanced would they be
technologically right
anybody can you hear me here and then
they just [ __ ] leave you to start all
over again and then that would basically
be that this would be a global like
survivor like this big [ __ ] reality
show that they're watching here's a
question any Scientologist listen to
this here's my question that goes how
this reminds me of this Joe Rogan bit he
used to do about Noah's Ark where he was
talking about how many species of plant
are on the planet and if he had two of
each and he was like how big is this
[ __ ] boat doesn't that kind of work
with Scientology like do you guys have a
finite number of members that you can
have and at that point like the
spaceships not gonna be big enough or is
it gonna be a whole fleet I don't know I
don't know why that religion has been
interesting meaning interesting me
interesting I think right there I just
got gap we don't need this guy all right
how have look how long of humans been on
earth why can't they just answer the
question this is what I [ __ ] hate
about smart people they got to go on and
on and on it starts off while
our ancestors have been around for about
6 million years just give me a number
what am i buying a [ __ ] car here
while I'm ancestors have been around for
about six million years the modern form
of humans only evolved about 200,000
years ago
yeah weren't there like two different
kinds and one of them lived and the
other ones didn't there's somebody beats
somebody else I don't know the only part
I don't think I know about that history
is movies not even documentaries that's
how not read I am I don't even watch
documentaries civilization as we know it
is only about six thousand years old
so does that mean running water that
goes back to Roman times
they held the title for four thousand
years before they whacked Jesus was that
their downfall they killed Jesus
is that what happened or did they
stretch it out too far like Hitler do
they fight a war on two fronts I mean it
all just [ __ ] melts together after
well doesn't it
all right about six thousand years old
and industrialization started in the in
earnest only in the 1800s ah Jesus yeah
future generations are paying for that
but I'll tell you what a [ __ ] life
we're living flat-screen TVs and [ __ ]
cell phones
speaking of cell phones Helsinki I'm in
Helsinki this is where Nokia started
Angry Birds
what else are they known for here hockey
Valtteri Bottas
huh who [ __ ] won I got this I got to
see that race this is going to be like
the first year I watched when a Lewis
Hamilton went up against the other guy
there that little Ricky Schroder looking
dude Nico Rosberg and he [ __ ] one
beat Lewis Hamilton and then his
girlfriend was like I don't want you to
do it anymore and he was like all right
I don't think that's what happened
because he still stayed away at some
point he would have dumped her he would
have missed the sound of the engine
right alright so I guess we've been
around for 6,000 years as we know it
200,000 years ago the first [ __ ]
humans
I'll tell you what's [ __ ] amazing
about all of this is I have no idea why
I even [ __ ] look this up I don't know
okay it can't really be this this is my
new thing how I deal with my short-term
memory when I can't remember stuff I
just think we you know if I can't
remember it was it really that important
anyway plowing ahead here here's a great
story it's not a great story it kind of
yourself all right
oh wow why do they do that [ __ ] we're
gonna make you watch this [ __ ] ad I
don't want to watch it close the [ __ ]
ad I'm gonna hit mute cuz they don't get
paid is that what the [ __ ] it is stop
stop thank you alright
Avenger fans brutally beat man outside
cinema after he loudly revealed the
surprise ending to the blockbuster and
game movie I love both sides of this
story I mean that is just the ultimate
kunti thing to do what's so [ __ ]
funny and then I got to admit you have
to respect how much people care about
this franchise and if you're gonna do
something like that I mean he kind of
got the ass kick and he deserved right
thank God it was a mob and nerds or he
beat [ __ ] dead
do you realize what you have to do I
mean nerds are supposed to be these
nonviolent people who just kind of sit
around and be awkward all the time I
love that they [ __ ] tapped into their
inner Chuck Norris you found the
breaking point you go in and you [ __ ]
with their superhero franchise look at
them they turn into their cavemen selves
from 200,000 years ago look at me
sounded smart all of a sudden I mean
they surpassed modern civilization as
we've known it for the last 6,000 years
and went back to our earliest ancestors
a 2,000 years listen to that huh at the
beginning of a Dennis Miller joke I
think I'm smart now a man has reportedly
been beaten outside beaten up outside
his cinema after loudly revealing the
plot of the new Avenger film
- queuing fans queu ing there you go
that goes on my Dennis melon element
dummy again film queuing - queuing fans
who hadn't seen it yet
so he walked out of his showing and they
were all standing in line and he but the
Hulk is green cuz he has gonorrhea nurse
whatever the [ __ ] II yelled up because
they're all banging Wonder Woman is this
even the right franchise someone was
trying to tell me that they've made 23
of these movies 23 of these [ __ ]
movies just just for all you other
people who just watch sports like me
just to give you a motive for how this
guy turned a pack of [ __ ] awkward
nerds so you could probably walk up slap
him in the head and take their [ __ ]
popcorn and they wouldn't do anything as
long as they held on to their movie
ticket this guy found out what it was it
reminded me of a long time ago this guy
ran for president that I voted for and I
can't even remember his [ __ ] name he
was the guy that everybody blamed for
the first George Bush for getting in you
know cuz everybody made the assumption
that if you voted for this guy then then
if you didn't vote for that guy you
would have voted for [ __ ] Al Gore
forgetting the fact of how [ __ ]
horrific Al Gore was all [ __ ] sweaty
al you didn't laugh enough in the last
debate you didn't smile then also just
like ha ha oh ha ha looking like a
[ __ ] robot
let me see well looking back that wasn't
[ __ ] era we should you know I didn't
give a [ __ ] of your conservative I think
we should have gone Al Gore you know
then maybe we don't go to Iraq and
become bankrupt and have to give
Champions of sports fast food when they
show up at the White House I'm probably
oversimplifying all of this but you know
I'm a man who just learned how long
we've been on this planet so why why are
you listening to me alright what the
[ __ ] am I talking about here yeah so
this guy found the [ __ ] it's anybody
made 23 of these [ __ ]
movies so let's just say the average
movie is 90 minutes 2 hours long ok
these poor people standing in line had
46 hours invested into this wall wait
we'll say 44 hours well plus the trap
fell all the [ __ ] money that they
spent and this was the final one and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I wonder if he was
even a fan if he just went in like this
was like some sort of like I mean that's
like something Opie and Anthony would
have come up with back in the day like
some brilliant [ __ ] thing like that I
don't know this is one of these weird
ones where I kind of see both sides of
it like what that kid did was [ __ ]
hilarious and it was also horrific and
he deserved the ass-kicking I'm on both
sides of the fence here
I would love to interview this kid and
ask just ask him why did you do that did
you know you were gonna do it do you
have Tourette's or something like why
the [ __ ] did you do that and what were
you thinking when they started to attack
you do you regret doing it I don't know
I mean if I'm sitting on that jury I say
that those fans had motive if I'm
arguing I mean these that's like you got
to think how young the average [ __ ]
fan is of this I mean they invested half
their [ __ ] lives into this this guy
just came in and told him what Llano
what chimney Santa Claus was coming down
I you know what I have no I don't know
there's so many of these [ __ ] things
that people are telling you you got a
why have you seen Game of Thrones
have you seen [ __ ] what does this one
called
the Avengers and you just get so like
[ __ ] hopelessly behind it reminds me
of my junior year in math my senior year
junior year I still tried I tried until
October and it just gets to this there's
like a point were you just so far behind
that you just give up hope
like I'm not passing I can't what day
I'm just too far behind like I don't
think I'll ever see Game of Thrones
which is a sad thing because I know it's
really good I just you know what is
there like 19 [ __ ] seasons or
something you got a [ __ ] uh I
remember lost lost was the first one
that I was just like I was too far
behind and I was just like I I'm not I'm
not [ __ ] watching this and then they
[ __ ] everybody on the ending of that
so that one I feel good about maybe
that's the way you do it what you do is
you let other people go on point and you
let them watch the show for you and then
they'll report back to you like oh my
god that [ __ ] ending sucked what a
waste of [ __ ] time there you go all
right we'll [ __ ] that then right all
right so Avenger fence is it worth me
sitting down for 46 hours that should
literally be like a [ __ ] you know if
anybody who can stay awake for 46
straight hours and watch all Avenger
movies right in a row the last person to
fall asleep the last person to fall
asleep
I don't know when's the two big green
Hulk fists whatever the [ __ ] you people
are into [ __ ] somebody just sent me a
text I was trying to think of the name
of this [ __ ] comedian who I just
doesn't do it anymore probably is into
producing or something like that
whatever what either way I hope they're
happy just yeah buddy says somebody's
[ __ ] ahead that face pops into your
head you know what the [ __ ] was that
guy's name I haven't seen him forever
you know sudden you can look them up on
Facebook and see where the [ __ ] they're
at then you see how much older they are
then you realize that you look that much
older to them and you don't recognize
any of the people that they're with and
it's like did I ever even [ __ ] know
that person you know then you just start
thinking like what is it all about what
the [ __ ] of my
doing out here is this what my life is
going to beautiful cities for 17 hours
then getting on another plane and
leaving then you look to see if they got
a late night menu and you start ordering
bad food and you know just start
spiraling down no I've been doing uh I
didn't do well in Iceland I was on
vacation when I was in Iceland and then
I Oh Billy was getting uh was getting
the old belly coming back but I don't
know I had a couple of [ __ ] moments
there I vote we don't like going fishing
I like it and but then I don't like it
it's exciting and all of that but like I
just don't like it's weird cuz I've
eaten so much fish in my life but to
actually [ __ ] pull it out of the sea
see how beautiful it is and then [ __ ]
kill the thing you know I mean I felt
bad I didn't even heat the [ __ ] head
- it's like Jesus Christ dude what the
[ __ ] you know I know we threw the rest
of it into the [ __ ] ocean but it
bugged me the cows I didn't even know
cows were that good-looking so this is
what I'm doing now cuz you know what's
funny is I know all you guys are
cringing on oh my god is he gonna start
wearing Birkenstocks and becoming Bill
Birkenstocks right he's gonna get a
[ __ ] I'm gonna scotch tape a man bun
to the back of my bald head and then I'm
gonna start preaching to you guys about
[ __ ] being a vegan oh dude this is
such a [ __ ] up analogy man because I
got to tell you something like you know
how cruel they are to [ __ ] animals as
a carnivore and you just don't want to
watch it if you have any sort of heart
you just don't want to watch it and you
just [ __ ] block it out I saw this
thing where there's some conservative
talk show host that got a [ __ ] death
threat so I'm like who the hell is this
guy I don't know this guy so I looked
him up and he did this [ __ ] thing
some rant on like abortion and you know
he showed I I saw like 0.5 seconds he
showed a picture of an abortion I was
just like dude what the [ __ ]
you know I'm not gonna get involved in
my views on that thing I you know
whatever you want to do is whatever you
want to do but you might want to look at
some photos jesus [ __ ] christ it's
one of the worst things I've ever seen I
probably shouldn't have said that
cuz now his fans are gonna say I'm not
gonna get involved in that [ __ ] and I
don't want to [ __ ] sit there because
I don't I don't know [ __ ] alright so
don't [ __ ] I'm not an ally of either
side of that [ __ ] argument I think
it's your own [ __ ] do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do okay but yeah you
should probably look at a slideshow
first that's all I can say
so I haven't said that this is what I'm
gonna do now I think when I'm on the
road I'm gonna be vegetarian for the for
like for breakfast I know I had eggs oh
that's still vegetarian right no that's
a meat I already [ __ ] it up whatever I
was gonna be trying to go veggie for the
first for breakfast and then for lunch
and then for dinner I'll have a left
something you know and I'll see how that
goes I've been doing that for the last
couple days and it's good I started I'm
dropping [ __ ] weight you know I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] racehorse it's ridiculous it's
like I'm going to bathroom like a
[ __ ] cokehead
[Music]
people looking at me waiting to sniff
it's like gotta you're looking at the
wrong and they're all right abortions
[ __ ] jokes dead animals where else do we
go from here
World War three I think we pretty much I
think it's time for some advertising all
right let's do it here what do we got
here we got oh this is a long long hey
look you know write in about that write
in about [ __ ] remembering faces but
forget in the names and then you
remember them and then you go on
Facebook and try to look them up and
just see whether where the [ __ ] they
ended up you know whenever I do that I
just said I pray to God they're happy I
want to see joy that's what I want to
see you know I'm not I'm not as big a
[ __ ] as everybody thinks
all right here we go where am i where am
i where am i Jesus oh my do you want me
to read all of this okay oh Jesus
well how ironically after what I was
just talking about butcher box butcher
box is it ironic because of abortion
talk or is it ironic because of [ __ ]
veganism who knows you you make your
choice it's up to you um all right
butcher box everybody I got to scroll
back up here right now
butcher box is offering new members two
pounds of free wild-caught alaskan
salmon 20 dollars off their first box
butcher box sources their pure wild
sustainably harvest salmon from Bristol
Bay Alaska you can tell by the color
that this salmon is always fresh never
factory farmed new members will get two
pounds of wild caught Alaskan sockeye
salmon these must mean this must be the
tough fish huh [ __ ] you look at it
for free plus $20 off your first box
this is an awesome deal I'll tell you
right now I can never be a vegan because
every time I read this my mouth waters
butcher box makes it easy to get a high
quality meat that you can trust every
month butcher bucks delivers 100%
grass-fed and grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork my favorite and while the
last can salmon directly to you Dilla
the incredible quality of butcher box
meat starts with the commitment to
humanely raised animals that are never
fed antibiotics or hormones did we
mention it's delivered right to your
door choose from four curated boxes
including a mix of high-quality
grass-fed grass-finished beef what
grass-fed grass-finished beef Oh cuz you
can say grass-fed and then they feed it
another cow you got to make sure you
said grass finish - free-range organic
chicken and heritage breed pork or
customize your own box so that you can
get exactly what you want and your
family what you and your family loves
sorry now for $20 off one more time your
first order and - three pounds of wild
Alaskan sockeye salmon go to butcher box
calm /tpour or rent the promo or enter
the promo code bar Oh Mother's Day is
coming up everybody and
guess who's back on the podcast sharise
berries huh sharise berries that that
they're like my [ __ ] they like my meg
Ryan and When Harry Met Sally
what together we're broken up what
banging we're you know separated
cherries berries Mother's Day is coming
up and there's absolutely nothing most
of us wouldn't do to make sure the
special moms in our lives are happy talk
about your mom's and why she deserves to
be happy this month because she's my mom
I have to go into [ __ ] detail how bad
was your mother sherry that I you she's
my mother talk about the best worst
funniest reaction you received after
sending a Mother's Day I always send her
something nice I give her a great card
and she smiles she hugs me tells me she
loves because she's mean she's the best
motivate your audience I know what I'm
doing talk about your Jesus Christ
Sherry's berries has special Mother's
Day berries designed just there like
Michael Douglas in that [ __ ] movie
don't dance like you tell me I know what
to do in the [ __ ] copy cherries
berries has special mother days berry
designed just for Mom that are topped
with chocolate chip pink shimmer sugar
and swizzles describe how much these
gourmet goodies would make the special
mom in your life smile well every day I
think she would like chocolate chips the
best I would think I hope she would you
know wait till she brushed her teeth
afterwards before she smiled you know to
be perfectly honest with you you choose
your delivery date to ensure mom gets
your gift of Sherry's berries exactly
when you want or to and your
satisfaction is always guaranteed don't
wait until the last minute on this one
visit berries com to order today freshly
dipped strawberries starting in 1999 for
the mom in your life or mom's plural now
what's that for is that for people who
say my mom's or is that the people with
alternative lifestyles or is it for
everybody I don't know to make mom
really happy you could double the
berries for just $10 more Mother's Day
is Sunday May 12th so visit berries calm
that's B E
RIE s.com click on the microphone in the
upper right corner and enter my code
burr that's Barry's comm click the
microphone code burr alright and lastly
but not leastly quip the new kids quip
has the same two minute timer and
guiding pulses as our original version
with no childish gimmicks so they can
brush just like a grown-up motivate your
audience thought well what the [ __ ]
isn't it's a toothbrush you know I was
never an electric toothbrush guy you got
to do it if you have the regular ones
that your gums you brush your gums away
is what happens and then you get a
periodontal [ __ ] issue right and then
you're gonna get decay and then your
teeth fall out then you have stomach
problems and then you die so I think you
should get this toothbrush how was that
quit kids the the new brush is the same
as our original version just tweak for
size down mom oh they got them for kids
now I'll have to get my daughter one of
these you know if you sent me a free one
maybe I could talk a little more
informed about it wink wink nudge nudge
steer kids are inspired to brush better
and more often with oral care that looks
and feels like the products the adults
in their life use and they they're proud
to use quip help them develop a grown-up
routine without childish gimmicks
kid-friendly features like a small brush
head watermelon act anti cavity
toothpaste and rubber grip handles and
colors little ones will love sensitive
sonic vibrations for an effective clean
that gentle that's gentle on your
sensitive gums why people brush too hard
in some electric toothbrushes are too
abrasive built-in two-minute timer
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides and help you to
clean your whole mouth that's why you
should love quip and why over 1 million
happy healthy mouths do too uptight man
you get this thing and you floss and you
actually pay attention to the beeping
and all that type of stuff you're gonna
save yourself an incredible amount of
headaches in your life you can have a
beautiful smile you're not gonna get
your teeth polled and have to get a
partial and all of that [ __ ] crap and
you won't ruin your stomach
because y'all should be able to chew
your food anyways kripp starts just 25
bucks and if you get too cool if you get
quip comm qu IP / / right now you can
get your first refill pack for free
that's right your first refill pack for
free at GE t qu IP comm / / all right
beautiful
and that's it and of all freckles I'm
going to uh this is what I'm going for
and here in Helsinki I'm getting fresh a
fresh seasonal salad then I'm getting a
salmon soup so what I'm [ __ ] trying
I'm trying
in any vegetarians or vegans out there
that you know you got some good meals
that I can kind of toss in there I'd
love to do it because I'm feeling pretty
good feeling light on my on my freckled
toes here my freckled pasty toes just
don't give me any that tofu [ __ ] all
right
I don't like tofu I don't know what tofu
is I don't know what it's trying to be
and I also don't like that [ __ ] where
it's like you know what they have like
the fake meat like I like a black bean
burger you know or if you make a lentil
burgers it's actually made from
something I don't like when they just
mush a bunch of [ __ ] together and then
try to make it look like meat it's just
like you know it's like be yourself you
don't be who the [ __ ] you are
I have a great recipe for a lentil
burger where it's also like it's got
beets in it there's cilantro and some
other green [ __ ] that you put in there
and a little bit of bread crumbs
it's [ __ ] tremendous but it's hard to
eat that when you're out here on the
road that was the one thing I did like
about Iceland though as as much as I
didn't order anything like that they did
have plenty of options so anyways I'll
see how this goes you know I think I'm
always going to eat meat but I think I'm
gonna do it like once a day as opposed
to like [ __ ] three times a day
and part of its because of animals I'll
tell you what's weird about pigs is if
you see a little piglet they're [ __ ]
adorable and then you think I can't
believe I eat that then you just see
some
pick and it's just like I don't give a
[ __ ] give it to behind its pinkier let's
[ __ ] eat anyways alright that's it
thank you - everybody's been coming out
on this tour man I'm playing these
[ __ ] really impressively sized venues
over here that have been absolutely
beautiful and it blows my mind that
people are coming out here so I do want
to take the time to say thank you for
that and I'm really looking forward I
got two shows here tonight and in
Helsinki and then it's on to Oslo Norway
and then I'm in Amsterdam and we got the
next day off and I'm in Amsterdam
although we are traveling to Tel Aviv
but uh you know that's gonna be fun put
it that way but I'm not drinking you
know I think I'm gonna eat like a pot
cookie or something like that and just
walk around the city mildly tripping I
will not be getting on a bicycle but
yeah that's what I'm gonna do I think
that's what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do you
know good clean fun all right that's it
enjoy your weekend you [ __ ] enjoy the
music and we've got another half hour
the greatest hits of a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts from
I always forget how he does it alright
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 2nd 2011 how the hell are you
this is a landmark week from me in my
career and and in this podcast because
for the first time I'm actually I have
an advertiser no [ __ ] I have an
advertiser like a real live radio show
on this podcast and I know what you guys
are thinking you're probably like oh gee
he's got advertising so what does that
mean bill does that mean you're not
going to use the word [ __ ] anymore no it
does not does that mean you're gonna
tone it down no it doesn't all it means
is that it continues to be [ __ ] free
for you cheap [ __ ] not kidding
not cheap just financially challenged
[ __ ] you still [ __ ]
you're still [ __ ] of mothers but
anyway so this week for the first time
ever I do have gonna have some
advertising and I'm actually working on
some t-shirts and that type of thing I'm
trying to take this thing to the next
level maybe you have a merch page
whatever the hell I got to do I
appreciate everybody who's gone on to
the mmm podcast page and clicked on the
donation button I appreciate it I really
appreciate it so with that this week my
one and only advertiser the first ever
pledge is one of these legendary moments
in the podcast like when I when I I
switched from yapping on my phone as I
drove down the street and I actually got
a mix this is the first advertiser
you're probably thinking hey Bill what
are you gonna do you can advertise some
booze you can advertise some weed no I'm
not I'm actually gonna give a lot of
guys out there a little bit of a heads
up Mother's Day is coming up this Sunday
isn't it I don't know I didn't look it
up I think it is
see this is what happens every mother's
day bright who doesn't love their mother
serial killers
right serial killers don't love their
mothers everybody else you love your
mother right but as much as you try
every year what happens Mother's Day
sneaks up on you and all of a sudden
Saturday night you're out drinking a
couple of beers a couple of [ __ ] Pale
Ales and all of a sudden somebody
mentions it you know the waitress with
the [ __ ] cleavage hanging out she'll
mention oh yeah tomorrow you know you're
trying to pick her up yeah what are you
what are you doing tomorrow maybe we
should hang out go play [ __ ]
horseshoes or something you know my
brother's got a cottage up in New
Hampshire dode she come up there and
then she's like I can't I um I'm
spending time with my mother's tomorrow
because it's Mother's Day and then what
do you do you go oh [ __ ] it's Mother's
Day so what do you do you run down to
CVS you know any port in a storm you run
down to the local drugstore and you're
going you try to find a [ __ ] Mother's
Day card but by the time you get down
there there's only two left right what
do you got there's the [ __ ] one that
has like a fart joke on it and then the
one that's so affectionate it's
borderline incestuous right so now what
do you now you got a shitty card the
[ __ ] envelopes are all creased up
there laying all over the [ __ ] place
and your mother can see it when you hand
it to her she could see it it's not a
good card it's just like you
[ __ ] I carried you around on my
[ __ ] home for nine months I raised
your brat ass the entire [ __ ] life
and this is what you do you get me the
goddamn leftover card that nobody wanted
at CVS you couldn't even go to Walmart
and get me a shacket to go along with it
all right well I have the solution this
is a classic thing for guys my sponsor
this week is proflowers.com all right so
all I got to do is uh want me to read
their copy rather than tell my silly
little story
hey everybody Mother's Day is around the
corner and ProFlowers always has great
specials for radio listeners exclamation
point at proflowers.com you will find
huge selections of gorgeous gorgeous
Mother's Day bouquet starting as low as
$19.99 plus you get a free
with every any floral purchase isn't
that great you get a free vase you know
just lay it in a lap like she just ran
the [ __ ] Kentucky Derby you know at
that rate you can get flowers for all
the moms in your life your mother your
grandmother he assists his mother I
didn't make any sense your girlfriend's
a mother anybody any broad in your life
you want to send flowers this is the
website you go to all right if you want
to call him up and you can get this [ __ ]
out of the way so you can watch the
games the playoff hockey and the NBA all
that call 800 ProFlowers and mention the
Monday morning podcast Bilborough say my
name so then I get credit or better yet
as they say go to proflowers.com click
on the microphone in the top right hand
corner that's the big thing when you go
to the website there's a microphone
right when you go to ProFlowers and you
just the upper right hand corner it says
here about us on radio or TV just click
right there then you type in the
password which is my last name bu RR
pick out some flowers bang zoom they
[ __ ] send it right to your house you
hand it to your mother you take out a
ukulele you get down on one knee your
singer a song and you're done the next
thing you know you guys are both
drinking booze right there you go see
wasn't that painless told you a little
funny story I read the copy I got it out
of the way so seriously guys if you want
to order those things you know if you
want to do it go to proflowers.com
there's a microphone right in the corner
you click on that you type in the
password birbee URR and i'll actually
get the goddamn credit all right there
you go and with that let's get on with
the podcast all right it was like old
school the host of the show was doing it
like in the 1950s you know this is the
Crest toothpaste our hello folks say
your teeth falling out of your head did
you not notice because you've been in a
mine for the last 20 years and you don't
belong to a union thank God for crest
it's got fluoride soon to be in your
drinking water so you're a lot more or
less a days lackadaisical however you
say the [ __ ] word and you're less
likely to question authority I am in New
York City people you probably like why
bill why are you in New York City I'll
tell you why me and Joe DeRosa and
Robert Kelley you heard last week we
our film debuted in the prestigious
Tribeca Film Festival and I went to two
of the screenings I'm going to another
screening tonight and I got to tell you
something that is the most nervous I've
ever [ __ ] been I'd have to go back to
the first time I did Letterman or maybe
the first time I even did stand-up just
the the feeling of like what if this
goes bad and I have absolutely no
control if it does and fortunately it
went well and I got to tell you
something I don't say this too often I
was really proud of I was proud of it
you know I knew we didn't pull any
punches but when I saw it watching it
with the crowd was a whole different
vibe plus watching it up against some of
the other movies you know I was really
nervous because their movies were they
were they were great and some were
really serious and I was just going oh
my god what the how the hell czars gonna
hold up against it unfortunately it did
and we've had a great festival and
tonight it's the last night
and I got to tell you people I have
never been more tempted to booze since I
quit booze and then this goddamn week
but I got 200 days coming up I didn't
want to [ __ ] that up and then once I go
over 200 days that's it I'm just gonna
[ __ ] I think I'm just gonna pull
myself out you know like Cal Ripken I'm
just gonna say all right to hell with
this [ __ ] you know [ __ ] it what more do
I need to prove so like I have a
drinking problem I just have a huge head
problem do you guys know that that's
really the real reason why I quit not
because I was getting drunk coming home
blaming my day on Nia slapping around on
a kitchen table and then later taken out
a [ __ ] frozen box of peas and putting
it on the side of her [ __ ] left titty
because I gave her a [ __ ] uppercut
right that's not why it's because I
already have a giant head a pumpkin head
as some of the people on the internet
have said
[Music]
[Laughter]
which always makes me giggle um that's
why I quit drinking I just got sick
there's something like look who's
kidding though you hit middle age and I
don't give a [ __ ] you just don't look as
good but there's no reason to help it
along you know what I mean it's pure
vanity that's why I [ __ ] stopped and
you know you know the deal you know in
the Broads they [ __ ] hit middle age
they've they've squeezed out a couple of
[ __ ] kids now they resent the [ __ ]
anybody who has free time you know
because they made a decision to take a
hot one right between the [ __ ] legs
you know that was your choice I want to
have a kid that's so cute then they have
one and then they're a bunch of [ __ ]
it's Mother's Day this week everybody
let's not lose sight of that bad yeah
mothers are just they're [ __ ] pains
in the end another reason to go to
ProFlowers just get my bouquet and shove
it in their face all right already we
got it you agree you'll regretted your
decision and I'm a [ __ ] reminder of
it
so anyways I'm already picturing profile
which people listening to it that's just
such let's you know is this
groundbreaking way of selling flowers
because it seems weird to me
anyway I talk about how people age right
so what do women do okay then they have
a couple of kids
and they're so [ __ ] goddamn busy
alright that not only do they not have
time to do a sit-up they don't even have
time to [ __ ] wash their hair anymore
so they all go out and get that Wayne
Gretzky haircut that he had when he got
married you know all short on the side
like Adolf Hitler and then they poof it
up on top you know
the KD Lang they get that haircut and
then like oh my god I love it it's so
easy to deal with right
not knowing that when their husband
bends them over they feel like they're
[ __ ] it dude you know a dude with
tits alright that's what you feel like
so that's how they H you know and then
what happens with guys guys age
like john travolta and alec baldwin it's
very rare that a celebrity will actually
just continue to [ __ ] and eat and booze
and do what regular people do and just
allow themselves to age the way regular
people do you know that [ __ ] you know
that deal we uh I don't know eat like a
pig all summer and then it comes to the
wintertime you take out your button-down
shirt and you got a t-shirt on
underneath it because you don't want to
sweat your way through it cuz you're
such a fat [ __ ] booze bag at that
point and then you just you don't even
notice and all of a sudden for some
reason you used to be you can only see a
t-shirt up top near your neck now you
can see it in between like each button
because the [ __ ] fabric of your
button-down is stretched so goddamn far
that's why that's why I quit booze and I
had you know every year I buy like four
or five button-down shirts and those are
my I'm gonna headline for an hour doing
comedy shirts right and they usually
last me a year but I had this one I
didn't even notice you know cuz you know
you put on a couple pounds a week you
don't [ __ ] notice almost I was taking
pictures in them and the button that was
right you know between my man tits what
it that the fabric was just it looked
like the shirt was gonna explode so
that's basically why I that's why I quit
the boozing so I recommend it I
recommend going off the sauce for a
minute so now what I want to experiment
with as far as my boozing and I want to
know if as anybody tried this I'm gonna
drink one day a month and when I do it's
it's gonna be [ __ ] epic I'm gonna get
it all out of the wall out of the way in
one day beer and whiskey all at the same
time giant chalices of [ __ ] booze and
then I'm gonna hate myself for like a
day or two and then I'm just gonna get
on with my month has anybody been able
to do that cuz I tried doing that last
time and then it became uh twice a month
three times a month and next thing you
know I'm doing a [ __ ] keg stand and
my face is turning red and I'm just like
what am i doing you know but I don't
think I'm an alcoholic I just have a
job where I can booze you know what's
the worst that happens I show up
hungover and I [ __ ] about how I'm a
[ __ ] loser and then everybody laughs
cuz they feel better about their lives
like he's doing worse than us this guy's
awesome so uh let me know if you guys
out there do you have any sort of uh do
you have any sort of I don't know like
has anybody been able to do that like
just say I'm I'm only drink Saturdays or
I drink one Thursday a month has anybody
been able to stick with that I don't
know that's my thing I'm afraid to go
back to it cuz I I was really I was
looking like well I don't look like a
Baldwin but my torso did you know I had
the Baldwin torso I had the John
Travolta torso you know a Ted Kennedy
body that's why the [ __ ] I was you know
who said that [ __ ] by the way Bill Maher
is in Rolling Stone this past week and I
read it and he said how you know he just
sticks to weed and they say do you not
like alcohol and he basically I'm
paraphrasing here he said he loves it he
said but as a guy after a while you just
have to stop drinking or you end up
looking like Ted Kennedy and it's
[ __ ] true especially it's a white
dude you get that WC Fields knows hey my
little chickadee you don't want to look
like that alright you get the yellow
eyes you get that [ __ ] jaundice oh
good but um anyways let's plow ahead
here so anyways I was talking about my
can I say anyways any more [ __ ] times
in this podcast
another thing that went on this week is
we had the second antisocial Comedy
Network show that we did up at Foxwoods
in a 4,000 seat theater and we actually
sold the thing out I was absolutely
blown away by not only the amount of
people showed up but how great the crowd
was everybody was talking about it for
those of you who are on the outside the
anti social network tour is put together
by Jim Norton little Jimmy from the
wonderful Opie & Anthony radio program
he put together this towards me Jim
Breuer Dave Attell and obviously Jim
Norton and we've been cell
a ton of tickets and it's been great
everybody does 20 minutes we come out we
hit you with our best stuff and we
kicked the [ __ ] out of that crowd and
they what they were just a great crowd
they laughed you could bring him up you
could bring him down they were just a
phenomenal crowd and then we just do a
little question and answering afterwards
like five minutes and then we [ __ ]
ourselves out afterwards taking pictures
signing [ __ ] and everybody goes back to
gambling and it was uh just this amazing
theater I was actually talking to Breuer
because I had this [ __ ] upper deck
and we immediately started talking about
playing wiffle ball and about whether or
not we could hit the upper deck from the
from the stage man and this one was it
was just close enough where it was a
nice [ __ ] poke but that would have
been a great time except the people who
run the theater would have thought it
was obnoxious you know look at these
guys you get to tell jokes and play
wiffle ball what the [ __ ] what next they
can drink every night but I want to
thank everybody who came down there and
if that tour interests you we've been
selling a ton of tickets down there in
Washington DC we're playing there on May
13th
so get your [ __ ] asses down there all
right look at it's a goddamn recession
you get four comics for the [ __ ]
price of one I am just whoring myself
odd cast proflowers.com now I'm hyping
the tour before I've even brought you in
hours worth the comedy how [ __ ] dare
I look at me I'm becoming a corporate
[ __ ] everything what were you guys do if
I just totally [ __ ] sellout on this
podcast I stop saying [ __ ] I actually
build a cubical around my bed I changed
the name of the podcast this is brought
to you by the Halliburton Monday morning
podcast that we do every day now because
the higher-ups are making us eight you
know Halliburton actually changed their
[ __ ] name that was a weird way of
saying um I was working down in Houston
Texas and that's where they have at
least their United States headquarters
and they used to have this giant sign
as you went to George Bush international
go [ __ ] yourself I love the Illuminati
Airport down there and they had this
giant sign down there that would say
Halliburton and they had such a bad
public image that they actually made the
sign a lot smaller and they kept making
it smaller and then now they've just
finally changed their names to like you
know grandmas cupcakes or something like
that something just completely
pedestrian you know it's funny I don't
even know what they do isn't that
typical isn't that just typical of some
whiny [ __ ] [ __ ]
I have no idea what they even do what do
they do
what are they as far as I know this is
my layman's understanding of what they
do is basically they say to the Pentagon
will you guys blow it up and then we'll
rebuild it we'll get our contractors in
there you know and we'll build a little
strip mall we'll stick your Starbucks in
there and way everybody's gonna want to
be American everybody's gonna want you
know [ __ ] fat I feel right now I just
went to a steak house and there was
these [ __ ] Real Housewives chicks
sitting up at the bar these four white
ladies you know just dress like [ __ ]
I'll tell you right now if you're a mom
and you still dress like you're out
there trying to get [ __ ]
you're just a terrible mother you know
and they should really they should
repossess your [ __ ] kids now this is
just gonna all be about mothers this
week as I try to get you buy flowers you
know what are you doing with your tight
[ __ ] jeans you know your [ __ ]
goddamn hip-huggers jeans goddamn
c-section scar just above your bedazzled
belts for [ __ ] sakes put some clothes on
you're a mother it's over you know do
you know I worked with someone recently
right and and they were [ __ ] you know
they mentioned that they had a kid so
I'm always asking about kids cuz I'm
seriously thinking about having one
you know sticking them in the corner
next to a vase you know just adding it
to like my possessions I'll have my
guitars I've got a couple of guitars
what else do I have I don't know a lot
of [ __ ] I got a desk I'll stick them
between the guitars in the desk just
have them onto there and like you know
when you have like those cakes that they
have under glass at diners I'll just
have a [ __ ] baby in there every once
in a while I'd use you and lift the lid
up just [ __ ] put it back over give it
a bottle knock it off hey knock it off
is it awake and I'll just just tap on
the glass that's really creepy no I've
been thinking about having a kid right
so I ran into this man after a show and
she was talking about her son it she
looked young right she was like 30 31
years old and I go uh I go how old's
your son she goes 11 and then she
mentioned she had a daughter how was
your daughter she goes 13 so I do the
math she had him at 18 and 20 and I was
just like Jesus Christ like yeah you
started young hunt she winks at me she
goes yeah got it out of the way she goes
now it's me time I'm just thinking in my
head what do you mean me time they're 11
and 13 the [ __ ] you - you know that's
why I really think it's a good thing
that I I haven't had kids yet because
I'm a selfish [ __ ] and I'm really into
doing [ __ ] for myself and there's just a
lot of people out there I don't know I
think they just have kids and then they
they don't know they stick them in front
of the TV watch a little television oh
and they're just bad parents and then
every once in a while you see a great
[ __ ] parent who's really involved
with this kid like this YouTube video
that somebody sent me this week this guy
sent me a YouTube video of his
seven-year-old son as a drummer this kid
is the [ __ ] not only can he play cuz
I've seen kids play before but he
actually sings along with the song and
he has a look of passion on his face
it's [ __ ] awesome you can watch all
these videos by the way on the mmm
podcast com
the only thing I will say to this
the dad is you got to get that kid some
sort of uh you got to get him earplugs
you got to get him those uh those vic
first earphones that you just put looks
like the kids gotta use a weed whacker
just have them wear those it'll seem
weird for the first couple of days but
I'm telling you the kids ears are gonna
be [ __ ] junk if you let them play
without earplugs uh take it from me I
suffer from tinnitus or tetanus however
the [ __ ] you say it and that's that
ringing in the ear but you know there's
nothing better than when you actually
see good parents and I get I get nervous
that I'm not gonna be a good dad and
whenever I see you know whenever I see a
bunch of [ __ ] women who are mothers
just dressed like they're out there
looking to get banged it's just like
there's no way you're a good mom
you can't be a good mom you dress too
nicely you know mom's look they wear
comfortable clothes they have that
[ __ ] look on their face like Jesus
Christ what did I do with my life that's
a mom yet sitting down there with ed
hardy panties on and then going oh yeah
my my daughter just graduated the
seventh grade really the [ __ ] are you
doing what are you out here riding on
the back of the Harley with your goddamn
ass crack showing you're not a mom right
there you ought to get a warning you
know you should get a warning dressed
like a mom get the [ __ ] out of here
sitting here drinking your goddamn booze
in the middle of the day with your bra
strap showing the [ __ ] is wrong with you
lady
am i wrong thinking that am I just being
selfish because you know when I become a
dad I still want to have a cool car I
don't have that [ __ ] van I won't have
a car that's cool and my kids aren't
allowed in it and when they asked me why
I'm gonna say cuz at your age you're
still a [ __ ] animal look at you you
got Cheerios all over your face you got
ice cream on your fingers I don't
remember you have an ice cream what is
that [ __ ] you think you're gonna get my
dodge [ __ ] challenge yeah I'm just
gonna have one nice car that's going to
be for me and Nia when we go out and we
get a sitter right that's that's the
let's pretend we don't have
responsibility car and we'll go out and
have a dinner and come back in a couple
hours and then we'll just have some [ __ ]
[ __ ] van a [ __ ] van with those
[ __ ] NASCAR Formula one seatbelts
that crisscross in front of you both for
safety and also so those little bastards
can't get up you know I still think I'm
gonna be a good dad despite the horrific
[ __ ] I'm saying right now somebody sent
me a great I mean oh by the way my
special is still showing still streaming
on Netflix by the way I want you guys
opinion I'm thinking the next time I do
is special I'm sending my special
directly to Netflix because I think when
I sent it to channels where they have
commercials and they censor it you're
not getting the rip the full-on ignorant
Bilborough experience are you you know
it just you know if you really want to
see the level of [ __ ] that I am you
have to have the uncensored version so
I'm thinking that that's the future
I'm loving it because people who watch
Netflix are there it they seem like
they're getting the real special to me
which means they either absolutely love
it or they think I'm the dumbest person
on the planet with that let's get into
advice for this week this podcast is
gonna be a little shorter than the
recently I've been doing like an hour
and 20 I think they're too [ __ ] long
so I'm gonna try to do about an hour
come right in at about an hour you know
that's just long enough for your commute
Oh before I read the advice that I tell
you guys I'm working I'm trying to work
on my temper now that I got the booze
under control and now I'm gonna work on
my temper see this is me slowly giving
into the fact that I'm gonna get married
at some point I can't even say that I've
got to get married and I'm gonna get
married at some point I'm gonna have
kids all right
first thing I had to do is I had to stop
drinking like I was pledging a frat that
was the first [ __ ] thing I had to do
you know although when I have kids I'm
gonna be really tempted at the end of my
long work day doing absolutely nothing
as a comedian you know not to just pour
that scotch with the one [ __ ] ice
Cuban and I don't want to do that in
front of kids maybe I'll have a shed out
back that's what I'll do all my boozing
right and then eventually you know I'll
think that I'm fooling everybody and
then I'll have a bottle in the back of
the [ __ ] half bathroom in the
basement you know in the back of the
toilet everybody had no I'm boozing and
then eventually when they have the
intervention will be out there in that
shed
bill thinks he's doing a documentary and
I'm gonna be [ __ ] sitting there
walking this is what I do most of my
drinking you know be all noble about it
I never do it in front of my kids you
know my kids being everything you know
eventually I'm gonna stop right and then
I come walking in there my whole
dissappointed family's gonna be sitting
there next to a bandsaw and I'm a
stubborn Irish [ __ ] I'm not
going to rehab go [ __ ] yourself
you go to rehab or we're all walking out
God more booze money for me I know what
the hell I'm talking about right now if
you guys been watching the playoff
hockey congratulations - everybody's
team will moved on the San Jose Sharks
the Detroit Red Wings the Nashville
Predators who would have thought who
would have [ __ ] thought who the hell
are they playing out there Kings are out
Ducks are out
oh man Coover Bank and then over in the
East who won jeez I don't know who won
series last week Tampa Bay Lightning
Washington Capitals Philadelphia Flyers
and I think that said I think that's the
those are all wait a minute
oh Jesus I almost forgot the Boston
Bruins beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] Montreal Canadiens
Oh was that enjoyable what a tremendous
series round of applause for playoff
hockey it went seven games like you knew
it was gonna and I thought it was a
tremendous series although I was a
little disappointed with certain members
of the Montreal Canadiens with that
[ __ ] level of hockey they're [ __ ]
hammer liqu Jesus Christ I thought he
was in some [ __ ] slapstick movie what
was he doing out there any time you went
move what [ __ ] skate the wind of you
skating by the guy would just fall down
how funny was it when what's-his-face
the Bruins announcer I could never
remember his name John whatever when he
[ __ ] he he goes here my leg goes down
like he was shot shut up I'm not a fan
of that over-the-top sort of [ __ ]
announcing but I that was so [ __ ]
called for when he said that it was
[ __ ] ridiculous but uh but I was just
it was a phenomenal series and I knew it
was going seven seven games and I was
hoping we were gonna win I'm not even
gonna talk [ __ ] you know I'm not even
gonna talk [ __ ] whenever you played the
Canadiens their fans even if that team
sucks they'd take them to the next level
as a [ __ ] awesome series and that
[ __ ] subhan guy man is the [ __ ] that
guy's a star and I love the way he plays
the game I even loved that annoying [ __ ]
he does I love it he's a gamer he's just
trying to knock you off your [ __ ]
game by being a [ __ ] I love it and he
can play the game and that [ __ ] goal
that he scored to send it into overtime
was there was just a [ __ ] laser beam
but I got to tell you there is some sort
of unwritten NHL rule that if the
Montreal Canadiens are down by a goal in
a deciding game I don't give a [ __ ]
whether you committed a penalty or not
you're gonna be short a man they just I
mean how many [ __ ] years in a row can
they do that for that team it's
ridiculous wasn't it enough that for all
those [ __ ] decades they got first
shot at every French born Canadian
player wasn't that enough that they got
they had their own draft pool in a 16
League they're so [ __ ] overrated with
their goddamn history and I love that
when Bruins fans talk to him now all
Canadian fans have his there
history what's what's the historical
playoff series record yeah that's right
go back a quarter of a [ __ ] century
since the last time you dominated us you
[ __ ] French [ __ ] you got nothing you
haven't dominated us since 1987 it's
over it's [ __ ] over now if you want
to trash us for not winning a cup I
don't have a dog in that fight we're
[ __ ] horrific it's pathetic we
haven't won in one in almost 40 years
you're a hundred percent in there right
but if you're gonna try and sit there
and act like you're in the way you're
not go do your [ __ ] homework there
Frenchie all right we've played you guys
11 times since 1988 we beaten you seven
[ __ ] times you have four and seven
against us we beat you in a seven-game
series we beat you all three overtime
games and last time we played you we
swept you won the last two games at home
so I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
and Dan Shaughnessy you lazy
[ __ ] if you're not gonna watch
hockey stop writing about it you know
that son of a [ __ ] when we won in Game
seven he still figured out a way to
shoehorn in the curse of the babe
horseshit that he always writes about
there's nothing funnier than watching
Dan Shaughnessy write about hockey he
knows nothing about it
he started bringing up Johnny Pesky you
know Ted Williams Bucky Dent he then the
man can only write one [ __ ] story if
there's not a ghost a goblin or a
specter in it he doesn't have to write
the [ __ ] article you know it's
[ __ ] ridiculous why don't you address
the real problems Dan Shaughnessy like
how the Bruins resented free agency not
only didn't didn't play the game they
[ __ ] resented it they didn't want to
[ __ ] pay anybody why not why don't
you talk about that well the Canadiens
drafting first pick of every French born
Canadian player why don't you bring [ __ ]
up like that as opposed to sounding like
you're pitching a show to go on after
ghost hunters Oh somebody get that guy a
hot comb and a [ __ ] book on goddamn
hockey all right let's plow ahead here
um advice advice for the week oh wait I
promised these guys I was gonna read now
that I've said [ __ ] 20 times I promised
that I was gonna read this thing three
times during the podcast so we're at the
half
my point everybody open yourself up a
beer go sharpen a [ __ ] pencil at your
cubicle or whatever the hell it is you
do there once again people Mother's Day
is this Sunday
all right don't be a douche just go to
proflowers.com
click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner when you type in the
code right bu RR so I get credit on my
podcast and just order some flowers
you'll get a vase you get the whole damn
thing
and then all I got to do is take her out
to the IHOP you know you get her some
pancakes
what does she like Eggs Benedict you
know just do something like that or have
your [ __ ] broad do it but this is the
thing look if you're a lazy bastard and
you want to look like a good [ __ ] this
year you could bang it all up you go
right to ProFlowers buy something for
your mother buy something for your
girlfriend's mother and buy some for
your grandmother all right
then everybody in your life with a
vagina can shut the [ __ ] up for a clock
them seriously you know what I mean
guys we don't like to shop I should
really stick to the copier Mother's Day
is right around the corner everybody and
ProFlowers has Mother's Day bouquets
starting at $19.99 visit proflowers.com
clip on the mic click on the microphone
in the top right hand corner and type in
my password be URR get her a bouquet of
flowers get her a goddamn face hand it
to her tell her you love her she's only
gonna be around for so goddamn long you
know it I know it you should be doing
this every damn year every [ __ ] year
all right you go there you take her out
the Denny's you know poro poro bowl of
corn flakes at that point if you got the
[ __ ] flowers and the vase don't be a
cheap bastard on this one you got to get
the vase to like I said don't lay it in
her lap like she just wrote a [ __ ]
horse okay you get a vase you know women
love [ __ ] all right and vase it's just
another thing all right that's the
commercial at the half-hour see look at
this look at this I'm getting the
information in I'm keeping it funny I'm
still saying [ __ ] this is phenomenal
all right advice for this week dearest
bill my entire life I've jumped
one long relationship to another oh geez
at the ripe age of thirty I've started
to see a pattern good for you there you
go that's right you've seen a pattern
now see people this is how you improve
your life rather than blaming others
it's like being a comedian how many
times can you bomb and say in this crowd
sucks at some point you got to look at
yourself you got a you got a little go
to the mirror and look at you a [ __ ]
booze bag freckled-faced like me a few
months ago
and say listen I got to lay off the
booze that I gotta I gotta I gotta work
on my act here so this is what this guy
is doing exactly you keep pulling fish
out of the same poison pond and you're
getting tired of it good for you sir
here's the pattern he goes I start when
I start dating a woman she's dolled up
she's in great shape she's fun to be
around she's always willing to go the
extra mile by doing little things to
show you she cares and she's willing to
explore enjoy and share my interests all
right starting off a little myopic she
dresses nice and likes to do the [ __ ] I
do all right after a few months one year
or two one year she dolls up about 50%
of the time she's still in good shape
she's fun to be around she's a willing
she's willing to explore and share my
interests one year on little by little
things start to disappear she dolls up
ten percent of the time she's an average
too punchy shape she's fun about half
the time and she's only willing to share
interests there that are already
developed oh so she doesn't want to do
any new things each girl seems to stray
further and further away from their
month one personalities at different
rates yet it it seems to always stray
away into the negative zone oh it never
gets better I again find myself in a new
relationship things okay so he gets out
of that one one year in he goes I think
I get in find myself in a new
relationship things are
fan-fucking-tastic I'm living the dream
yet I find myself terrified oh so I
guess he's in a new relationship when
will she stop darling up when will she
stop being easygoing when will that
little pouch start to grow above her
belt I'm jaded and scare
bill does the month one girl ever stick
around am i doing something to turn
these perfect girls into comfortable
couch potatoes I don't want to see
another one transform what do I do
I know it's human nature to get comfort
comfortable sooner or later to be able
to function as a normal human being it's
impossible to keep that one month girl
around but can't they just stay in the
one month a year category do they have
to go beyond the one year always far and
he said okay am I ready to get bill
burned people like that one I figure out
what the other one was it was wait I got
it here at the top of the page ah ginger
are all ginger snap
those are my catchphrases everybody
all right let's plow ahead here uh what
am i up to oh by the way I'm probably
gonna forget this so if my web guy is
listening please remind me to put up the
YouTube videos of that redheaded kid
there's some poor bastard this kid I
don't know how old he is he's like 12 13
years old and he makes these videos and
he's just he doesn't know any better he
lives in the middle of nowhere he's just
making a total ass of himself so every
time he panties a redhead you know he's
already in an awkward age and he's a
redhead and he's a redhead male so you
know that's just a [ __ ] hailstorm I
lived through it it's not a pretty sight
San Jose Sharks go up to nothing sorry I
got the game on in the background so
anyways yeah that's that's not a fun
time it's not a fun time for [ __ ]
anybody unless you know you're just one
of the popular kids so this kid keeps
making these videos so what happened was
was people started trash them because
that's what happens you know you put
yourself out there you're basically the
second you get on a stage or you film
yourself you've you basically you put
yourself on a dunking stool and given
the world a bunch of baseballs that's
basically what you've done this kid
didn't realize it so they start [ __ ]
thrashing him and rather than ignoring
it he's been responding to it and he's
yeah
into the camera this is a message for
all you haters out there I can make as
many videos as I want but I'm gonna
continue making videos so [ __ ] you he's
doing that and he has his faces all
[ __ ] freckled and red he looks like a
young malachi from children of the corn
he sings songs actually I got a name and
name here
Aziz from parks and recreation was down
I got to give him I got to give him
credit
Aziz Ansari he hooked me up with these
videos he goes you gotta check these out
because I was telling him you got to
watch that guy at the Del Taco who gets
knocked out three [ __ ] times in this
battle royal so whatever see you got I'm
hyping that video and I hope that I
remember to tell my web guy about it if
not I hope he's listening to this
podcast and I put it up because it's
[ __ ] hilarious so anyways let's get
back to this guy he basically asked me
how do I keep how does somebody stay in
the one month thing well let me ask you
this sir
how do you do over the year do you put
on any weight what do you do you know
this is the thing about relationships
that I learned is that they're [ __ ]
work and it's what you're discovering is
that what happens is you meet somebody
and yeah it's exciting it's new it's
like I know you go on vacation so you
never been to Miami you go to Miami
Beach it's gonna be [ __ ] exciting all
right you got another vacation you go to
Miami Beach again it's still exciting
but it's not quasi you keep [ __ ]
doing the same thing it's just natural
that you start taking things for granted
and it works on both sides what I would
do is if you want your girl to stay in
shape is I would keep myself in shape
and I if you're into a girl that stays
in shape and there's nothing wrong with
that by the way there's always on those
women shows that that's superficial and
blah blah and guys should look beyond it
[ __ ] you you're lazy and you want to eat
ice cream and you still want to get the
same amount of love like you like you
have an hourglass figure you know that's
just women pimpin guys okay if you want
a woman who's in shape why don't
you [ __ ] date someone who likes to
work out that's what I would do
who's into that type of [ __ ] who
considers that type of thing important
that's what I would do and then you kept
saying [ __ ] like she's willing to
explore enjoy and share my interests
well that's all well and good as long as
you're willing to do it with her and
also I would say that you know you know
what's a great thing to do in a
relationship is to have interests
outside of the other person and the two
you [ __ ] off for for an hour or two
every day you know like I can tell you
if I'm in a relationship all right and I
join a gym I don't want my I don't I
don't want my girl join in the same
[ __ ] gym I don't I want two hours by
myself
who's kidding ho 20 minutes on the
treadmill and B I'll lift weights
tomorrow but whatever say like an hour
to myself I listen to my music
you know I'm looking at the at the
[ __ ] ass and titties of other girls
right that's legal you know they're
walking around this sports bras I can do
that you know listen to my ac/dc [ __ ]
get pumped lie to myself like dude and
in the summer I'm putting up 225 kid
[ __ ] two plates on both sides dog I
can lie to myself you know but I
definitely think look I would just say
you know the next time your your your
tell your girl that's that's that's your
fear said you know look I just keep
being in these relationships and
everything just sort of winds down
everybody you know people are in good
shape I wouldn't you know I don't know
it's kind of a tough thing to say to be
like are you gonna become a fatty in a
year I don't dude you ever thought about
just being single and just tagging a
bunch of chicks who are in shape and
every night will be exciting and new
come aboard I'm expecting you so ride my
single [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] every
evidently the way you can get herpes
while still wearing a condom is is I
guess that the the party a dick that's
bhai
imaginal line they're basically the part
you know you put a condom on you roll it
down you always have it at [ __ ] 3/4
mass don't you mean if you stretch it
all the way down it doesn't [ __ ]
cover your whole dick there's always
gonna be the goddamn you know eighth of
an inch of shaft you know unless you got
a huge [ __ ] dick and you bought the
wrong condoms and half your dicks
hanging out hanging out right and the
condoms on top of your head and you have
dick looks like [ __ ] Arnold from
happy days remember that had he used to
wear or Big Al I guess that's how you
can get it I don't [ __ ] know I don't
wanna hear about STDs it just makes me
happy I'm in a [ __ ] relationship you
know anyway so let's plow ahead here
next next question here next [ __ ]
question bill big fan of your comedy
podcast listen to it every Tuesday on
the way home while I'm stuck in traffic
anyway here's my deal I moved to us you
know what I just realized I forgot to
tell you guys how I'm working on my
temper I decided to break it up into
chunks rather than just trying not to
lose my [ __ ] I just realized I got it I
just got to attack it in chunks so this
is how I'm trying to do it I'm just
working on my temper in the car
that's it and I've been meaning to get a
post-it and I'm just gonna draw a smiley
face on it and just stick it on the
dashboard that's what I'm trying to do
and I did it this morning I was able to
do it I was returning a rental car and
you know it's Sunday morning I get up I
jump in the car Ford Fusion great
[ __ ] car - man get in this car and I
they should be no traffic I should just
shoot right up get the car back by 9:30
so enough to pay for the extra day and
what happens there's all this
construction and I got to admit it took
me a while to lose my [ __ ] but when the
[ __ ] douche cut into my lane that was
it I just [ __ ] without even thinking
just just just pushing down on the horn
and when I stopped those like
[ __ ] it lost my temper I got a I got a
stop and then somebody else did
something and I [ __ ] late on the horn
twice so so I failed you know the [ __ ]
that's offsides through the officiating
has just sucked in the NHL this whole
[ __ ] place how bad were the [ __ ]
calls first game on both sides by the
way on both sides at least that first
period is what I really watched of the
Bruins Flyers by the way which is by the
time I you listen to this podcast let's
do it on Tuesday that series is gonna be
one one going back to Boston I think
this is going to be a great series and I
think it's gonna be one of those series
where yeah I don't know it's weird the
Bruins are weird they're just on their
game right now but when they're not on
their game they they just I don't know
it's like they're playing the [ __ ] I
skipped out in the Ice Capades so I
don't know I'm nervous about that
happening and I also what the Flyers did
to us last year but the thing is is the
Flyers have no [ __ ] goaltending as a
right now so Tim Thomas is just [ __ ]
ridiculous so I think we're gonna win
the series I actually think we might
take it in six games
if we win Game two we went in six if
they win Game two this [ __ ] going
seven that's my prediction everybody for
those of you want don't watch hockey you
probably don't give a [ __ ] do you all
right bill big fan of your comedy
podcast let's do it every Tuesday in the
way to work anyway here's my deal I
moved to Austin Texas about three
[ __ ] years ago because of a job
I just broken up with a longtime on
again off again girlfriend and was
finally done with the relationship I
made the decision to be single for a
while and enjoy the single life in
Austin worked out wealth but I soon
metal she turned out to be the girl from
me and I was soon shopping for rings so
we're getting married in the fall
congratulations and I moved in about six
months ago you see my girl is a real
hard worker as am i Jesus crisis is
[ __ ] long settle in everybody no one
has ever given us anything in life and
we both worked hard to earn what we have
because of our hard work we both have
success
for Korea's careers my Boston accent
just came out this successful careers so
she's busted her ass through college got
a job and bought a house in her own
impressive because she was only 24 at
the time god damn it I wish I lived in
Texas and could buy a house at 24 middle
of [ __ ] nowhere anyways and since
then we have worked hard to make it a
home together
all sounds good right yeah it sounds
great well there is a catch oh jesus
here we go
she has this friend who she's known
since childhood and they grew up
together this sounds like a [ __ ]
romantic comedy they are like sisters
blah blah blah she let her friend move
into the house before we met Oh No and
was barely charging the girl rent at all
she also had her sister move in but as
soon as we decided to live together her
sister moved out like a normal [ __ ]
person anyway so this friend of hers is
still living in the house even six
months after we got engaged and moved in
together not only did she stay she also
had her loser boyfriend move in while
living there and while living there she
bought a cat and a dog well I mean what
the [ __ ] dude how come you're not saying
anything oh well here's the next
sentence I had a million talks with my
girl about it and now it's wildly
inappropriate to have these people and
animals living in our house when we're
trying to start a family but she feels
responsible for the well-being of her
friend and doesn't want to throw her out
on her ass oh no holy [ __ ] dude how big
is this house anyways eventually I
talked my girl into sitting down with
her friend and her boyfriend and kindly
tell them it's time to start looking for
another place to live they agreed and
everything was all good so three months
later the friend still doesn't have a
job and her boyfriend is only working
part-time as far as I can tell they
haven't started looking for jobs or a
place to live I've heard her complaining
to my girl about not wanting to sign a
lease on a dump because she is planning
on getting a job and be able to afford a
nicer place soon yeah she's stringing
you along
it's [ __ ] she's the
laziest [ __ ] I ever met it sounds like
it dude the way you're describing it I
already hate her I'm coming home every
workday I come home from work every day
and her boy her and her boyfriend are
sitting on the couch playing video oh my
god I also recently found out that my
girl is not charging her friend any rent
at all and the boyfriend only pays 200 a
month which is nothing compared to what
he could be making with the [ __ ] but
we could be making with the roommate and
he's a [ __ ] loser as well thirty
years old and never had a full-time job
in his life he brags about not having
any debt all the time but it's because
he's a loser and he's been living off
his girlfriend's student loans and my
girls kindness for the past two years do
I have to read the rest of this we blow
through the last two paragraphs and
mursaleen and in this thing people try
to keep these shorter I suck at reading
here I would be constantly bitching
about these people to my girl but it
kills her to know that I'm not happy she
spends a lot of time trying to make my
life better and I can I really can't
stand to see her sad or frustrated she's
stuck in a tight spot yeah dude the same
thing she's doing with you that she
hates to see you not happy and she wants
to keep you happy she's doing that with
her friends she has to make a stand here
so he says so to make a point I've been
leaving my stuff out in the kitchen in
the living room and not cleaning up
after myself and in front of everybody I
tell my girlfriend to leave it that she
should that they should have to clean it
up because we're doing them a favor for
letting them live there I've pretty much
been a [ __ ] openly to them every
day for the last three months but they
haven't gotten a hint yeah they have
their [ __ ] deadbeats they're just
ignoring it so anyways but me behaving
like that makes my girlfriend
uncomfortable too so I backed off a bit
so the latest is that they finally are
starting to pick up on the fact that we
want them out and are making provisions
to move out but I've recently found out
that they are planning on moving in with
my girl's mom just down the street
her mom's thinks of the friends as a
daughter or a good family friend and is
allowing this this pisses me off because
I know they're just gonna mooch off her
mom just like they did my girl
so now I know I'm planning on having
another talk no don't do that don't do
that so now I am planning another talk
with them about starting their own life
separate from my girl or family but I
know they wouldn't get the message
unless I came out and became a complete
dick which would totally kill my
girlfriend what should I do this is what
you do all right
let him move into you my girlfriend's
mom's house let him [ __ ] do it get it
out of your house all right eventually
they're what they will wear out their
welcome at your mom's house and then
they're gone it's it's but but the thing
is right now is if you if you tell her
mom that they're [ __ ] deadbeats and
that type of [ __ ] if you'll either come
off like a dick or she'll say well then
to hell with that they're not moving in
and then they'll be like well we can't
move out of your place and now you're
stuck with them all right you have the
things that wouldn't leave in your
[ __ ] house and they're leaving let
them leave let them go down to your
sister's mom's house this is probably
William what you yeah you mean your
girlfriend's mom's house this is
probably where she learned that [ __ ]
behavior from you know so that's her
house right now what it is is you
personally hate these [ __ ] and
you want them to live in the [ __ ]
that they so rightfully deserve to live
in so what you're doing right now is
you're letting your your personal hatred
of them get in the way of your ultimate
goal which is to get them the [ __ ] out
of the house which is happening okay if
her mother wants to take them in let her
do it and eventually she will discover
that they're [ __ ] mooches now I know
what you're thinking like what kind of a
[ __ ] future son-in-law am i if I
don't give her the heads-up and I'm
telling you just judging by the way your
future bride is this is just how they
are they're giving people who get taken
advantage of by mooches and the same way
your fiancee is learning this lesson
your mother's going to learn the lesson
so the
people are actually great that they came
into your life because the the hopefully
you'll be able to use them as an example
all throughout your marriage whatever
their [ __ ] names are you gonna be
like well look we're gonna end up
another situation like Kathy and Michael
[ __ ] remember that when they sat on
the goddamn couch playing Atari for
three [ __ ] years yeah dude
listen you don't want to fight both
those fights you'll end up like America
you're gonna have two wars going on at
once you're gonna go bankrupt don't do
that [ __ ] alright
Iraq is your house let him go to [ __ ]
Afghanistan don't [ __ ] worry about it
or vice versa we went into Afghanistan
first I don't how to [ __ ] say it
I don't read I don't give a [ __ ]
douche bag of the week by the way is ham
Erlich from [ __ ] the Canadians that
guy's an all-star man he knows better
than that
flopping around out there like he's on
[ __ ] I Love Lucy or something doing a
good Carol Burnett Show doing a goddamn
sketch all right last one I'm gonna read
here everybody coming up on an hour
keeping this one nice and tight hey Bill
I love you stand-up comedy and your
podcasts are freaking hilarious thank
you very much I love what you're doing
and I hope you keep doing it Braille
undefended thank you I'm a junior in
high school and I really have a problem
with my mom's boyfriend yes I would
think so
for the obvious reason but we're not
gonna get into that because you're too
young to talk about it I don't know what
to do because my mom used to be really
cool and she would really listen to me
when her boyfriend wasn't around now
when he comes over she makes she makes
me cook my own dinner which isn't that
bad to do but the fact that she ignores
me and listens to him more than she does
to me is what really gets to me this guy
can be a real [ __ ] to me and my mom
out Jesus Christ and the thing is that
they fight all the time and yet they're
still together after five years you can
tell a douchebag when you see one and
this guy really takes the trophy of
number one douche bag in the country all
right you know what [ __ ] that douche bag
of the week is the due date and this
kid's mom
he even yells at my mom sometimes and I
felt the urge to confront him one time
and my mom is the one who get
mad at me for trying to defend her I
feel like this guy has changed my mom
from a nice cool mom to one of those
reality show moms who don't really give
a [ __ ] about their kids yeah see this is
why you gotta be careful who you let
into your life
this guy has kids and he treats them way
worse than he treats my mom I feel
really bad for his kids for having such
a bad father figure in their lives yeah
this guy's horrific he's now he's never
gotten violent with my mom I think but I
think my mom has gotten dependent on him
for some fucked-up reason yeah cuz he's
probably doing that he's working on her
self-esteem he probably criticizes the
[ __ ] out of her and he's turned a nice
positive great mom
into a negative person who's not paying
attention to her kid yeah she's got a
dump this guy and I'm pretty sure it's
taken a toll on what my mom is like as a
person I have no idea what my mom sees
in him because they have practically
nothing in common and he's a total
[ __ ] to her and to me what I really
need is advice on how I can handle this
situation what I can do to make this
situation better for me and my mom
besides choking this guy in the middle
of the night I would really appreciate
some sound advice from you even though
you don't have kids
I would also like to know if you were
doing any gigs or any shows around
Southern California because I really
like to see in person thanks Bill
all right this is what you got to do all
right this is very tricky one of the
hardest things to do is when somebody
you love is dating an [ __ ] to
approach them and say hey I think the
person you're dating is an [ __ ]
because they're gonna get unbelievably
defensive all right so I would leave
that part out of it what I would do is
when that douche bag isn't around I
would basically tell your mom what you
told me - the bad [ __ ] about him just
say listen you know I just feel like you
know you're not listening to me as much
as you used to tell her you love her
tell her she's the greatest mom and just
just tell her that you felt like you
used to be closer and that you feeling
like you're not as close as you used to
be and that you know you realized that
you're her time with her boyfriend is
important but I'd like to have
whatever scan scheduled some hang time
with you guys and you know what when you
guys are out there having a good time
maybe she can you know slowly turn into
that person she used to be and then
eventually kind of trick her into
talking about that guy and let her be
the first one this is this is down the
road let her want you guys you know have
you hanged eh
you know and I'll tell you right now if
if that guy gets in the way which he
probably will try to cuz he sounds like
an insecure douchebag that if you guys
are actually hanging out you know
there's a lot of like little Mussolini's
running around the world they just don't
have the [ __ ] charisma and the right
cataclysmic moment in history to take
power so what they do is rather than
ruining countries they just ruined
families everyone that they come in
contact with so this that's what this
[ __ ] is like and he'll probably try and
take that time away from you guys
because he'll be convinced cuz in the
back of his head I bet he knows he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or he's a paranoid
psycho and he thinks everybody's talking
about him anyways which of course you
attract what you fear in life so I think
just keep it about you and her tell her
how great she is Mother's Day is coming
up it's perfect and just say listen you
know I'm getting older these next few
years are gonna fly by you know I'd like
to take advantage of this time let's
spend time together you know just you
and me like we used to just one day a
week I respect your time with your
boyfriend but you know one day a week
I'm your son for Christ's sake we can do
this and like I said during that time
that douche won't be around it'll be
just the two of you I bet the old her
comes out a little bit if you do it once
a week it's like therapy and like I said
eventually you let you let her bring it
up let her bring up what that guy's an
[ __ ] you know he's kind of been a
dick you know what I mean he just kind
of sit there like yeah yeah I do know
you mean and just respectfully call the
guy an [ __ ] and as far as choking
that guy in the middle of the night
don't do that now don't do that wait
till you like high school years you know
wait till you hit your growth spurt you
know you start filling out you start
throwing the weights around that's when
you do it you know take a nice karate
class go with the submission hold that's
what I would do you know you choke them
out they just go to sleep you know
there's no concussion
there's nothing like he just takes a
little nap I'm not advocating violence
wink wink alright YouTube videos a week
that's gonna be the podcast for this
week here's the YouTube videos for this
week I already hyped that amazing
seven-year-old drummer
[ __ ] awesome these are all gonna be
on the mm podcast calm the official fan
page of the Monday morning podcast if
you'd like to donate
alright to the podcast is a donate
button right on the right hand side of
the homepage right underneath the
Facebook Twitter and all those logos you
just click on donate whatever you want
to give me I don't give a [ __ ]
$1 1000 I don't give a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
take any of it and anyways all these
YouTube videos will be up there next one
greatest dance number ever filmed
according to Fred Astaire who was
considered the greatest dancer of that
time but he was a phenomenal dancer but
he was also a white dude so he had an
advantage like the montreal canadiens
getting first pick of every French born
Canadian [ __ ] player that's what
white people were in Hollywood back then
but during this time you know and this
is this I think this is really cool that
Fred Astaire said this shows you what a
cool guy this was this guy was that he
gave he gave a shout-out to the Jesus
Christ where the [ __ ] the video now
what did I do
oh Christ what did I do that's not the
right one that's not the right one hang
on a second the hell did I do here all
right greatest the Nicholas brothers
hope I'm saying that right you gotta
watch this video even if you don't like
all those [ __ ] so you think you can
dance so you think you can do a split
and have your [ __ ] stick to the floor
you know well be the judge of that if
you don't like those [ __ ] shows you
gotta watch these guys these guys are
unbelievable it's called the greatest
dance number ever filmed in the
beginning you're probably not gonna like
it
cap Callaway's in their scat singing I
[ __ ] hate scat singing I I just don't
like it I don't
think it's a talent scuba that'd be my
boo rapido but that baby shut your
[ __ ] face learn how to play the
trumpeter shut the [ __ ] up I can't stand
it but at once he's done and he does his
little [ __ ] head bopping I never
liked that [ __ ] guy I used to like
him and one time I read Miles Davis
autobiography and he trashed Cab
Calloway saying that when he see vatted
somebody else for [ __ ] having drugs
on him you know which was basically the
jazz musician version of those [ __ ]
[ __ ] who ratted out actors for being
potentially members of the Communist
Party in the 50s to Joe McCarthy so [ __ ]
him but once he's out of it I write with
his stupid conk when he gets the [ __ ]
out of the goddamn video watch these two
guys it's un-fuckin'-believable man just
the level of talent that these guys have
is insane all right and then you know
last week i hyped those videos about the
new plan of the apes moving comic movie
coming out people send in some smart
chimp videos these things are [ __ ]
awesome one is of a chimp they stick a
peanut in the bottom of this giant
graduated cylinder and i got to be
honest with you i couldn't figure out
how to get this [ __ ] thing out of
there and this chimp figures it out I
think we're actually gonna facilitate
them taking over the planet if we keep
teaching them this [ __ ] at the very
least being smarter than half the people
in shop class then there's another video
another smart chimp trying to get them
to work together human beings are so
[ __ ] stupid this scientists out there
trying to get chimps trying to get them
to help like move a heavy piece this
heavy rock to get them to learn how to
pull all in the same direction teach
them that [ __ ] skill you know so
right there they can get me a bomb
shelter back in the day if he if he had
oh my god they're the [ __ ]
chimpanzees they're gonna rip Matt my
goddamn nuts off and my face off he
could go into your bomb shelter and
close that [ __ ] metal you're they
gonna teach him how to open it up and
then there's the last one Steve Vai
acoustic I know you're here and this is
I totally respect
Steve Vai he's one of those guys who he
was a hired gun during the hair metal
days and he survived he carved out his
own niche
he never stopped creating and he goes
around he sells out theaters he's making
his money I've told you guys that my
favorite behind the music of all time
was Vanilla Ice because he still had his
money after seeing all those broke
things I mean most of the guys a lot of
guys still had that money motley crew
still had their money I like that one
Aerosmith's was great because they still
had their money I just hated seeing the
guy I hate I hate seeing people fail I
hate it you know unless it's the
Canadiens the Yankees the Jets or the
Lakers
dude if anybody can tell me how the
Lakers aren't going to win the
championship this year with the [ __ ]
old-ass Celtics trading away Kendrick
Perkins and the Spurs losing to the
[ __ ] Grizzlies it's over there is no
[ __ ] way the Lakers aren't going to
win the championship score Detroit
Redwings I'm trying to jinx the Lakers
by saying that cuz other than that I
don't think there's anything stopping
them so anyways what the [ __ ] was I just
talking about I totally lost my frame of
thought my train of thought or my frame
of reference or in my world my frame of
thought I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] was
I talking about yeah it's gone people
it's gone forever that's how my brain
works all right in the end of the
podcast let's uh let's hype my dates
what do I got here coming up oh by the
way I told you guys I was doing David
Letterman that is not gonna be happening
because believe it or not
guess who got called back for another
episode of Glee speak in a dance and see
what you guys don't realize is when I
sing on the podcast I'm just [ __ ]
around I actually have a wonderful voice
and I am a triple threat I can deliver
the jokes I can sing the songs and I can
[ __ ] I can do a little shim sham I
can dance
yeah I'm they're bringing me back to
glee and I'm actually doing a singing
and dance number with that an
androgynous kid who hangs out with that
[ __ ] angry blonde chick we're gonna
be singing I want a new drug but we're
doing the club version so it's gonna be
really really sexy I'm we went to one of
those v-neck t-shirts that shows man
cleavage it's gonna be awesome so look
for that so I won't be doing Letterman
because of that and also I'm gonna be at
the antisocial Comedy Tour February
comes February May 13th and in
Washington DC go to antisocial comedy
calm for all your tickets and all the
links like I said these tickets are
selling very fast I don't know how long
we're gonna be doing this tour or how
long where I don't know that's hilarious
I basically said what I wanted to say I
want to say how long this tour is gonna
last or how long we're gonna be doing
this tour and I got right to the second
one on my brain just shuts off because
it works in a straight line yeah I don't
know how long we'll be doing this tour
and how long this lineup is gonna last
and I got to tell you it's been a long
[ __ ] time since I've been on a show
where I just stand and I watch the
entire show I'm a comedian nothing makes
me [ __ ] laugh and I am working with
three [ __ ] beasts on this and it's
worth every goddamn cent I guarantee you
so make sure you get your ass down there
and other than that I'm gonna be doing
Caroline's comedy club may 19th through
the 22nd and and then the Chicago
Theatre another antisocial Network tour
we added Seattle last week and we're
also doing Las Vegas all those dates are
up on antisocial comedy calm and that's
it and one last plug I got to do
Mother's Day coming up guys come on do
it for your mother go to proflowers.com
click on the the microphone in the upper
right hand corner when it asks you for
the code type in birbee URR and in shop
awake they'll deliver them right to your
house it's perfect you know don't get
yourself into that situation where you
are that's
been offsides thank you Jesus Christ
take your [ __ ] whistle out so anyways
go to profile probe Pro proflowers.com
click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner to type in bu RR is
the code get your mother some flowers
get your girlfriend's mother some
flowers get your grandmother's from
flowers for once be a swell guy you know
it's gonna be all set then you write
something nice in the card you're all
set you don't even have to leave your
[ __ ] house how great is that you know
if you're one of these people are you
scared of the internet are you like me
you know if that's what you like then
you can just call there's a 1-800 number
where the [ __ ] is it 1-800 ProFlowers
and mention the Monday morning cup
podcasts and my name Bilborough order
the [ __ ] flowers and that's it that's
the odd Jesus hour and 11 minutes I
still went over alright but I also did
10 minutes of commercials that's it
that's it for this week thank you to
everybody who came out and saw our film
cheek we're gonna be I think we're going
to be doing a film festival in Chicago I
will have more information about that
next week or in the upcoming weeks we
shall be in more film festivals and
podcast listeners will get a chance to
check out the film we're currently
writing a book and when that comes out
in the beginning of next year the full
short of the film sheet will be
available in the back of the book and
we're going to do a little tour
hopefully me Bobby and Joe will be
selling the books signing them taking
pictures smiling and waving in 2012
trying to sell as many books as we can
before old Jesus comes back and tells us
what a bunch of [ __ ] we are alright
that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any
[ __ ] I'll talk to you next week
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
those snakes action
[Music]
in
[Applause]
[Music]
you